stop being boring I have a real aversion
towards blurring I hate pawn I hate
things that are born and and I hate
looking at people's products that are
boring and business cards that are
boring and websites that are born and
marketing is boring and the way they
tell their story is boring chances are a
lot of this stuff for you and your
business is boring too but doesn't have
to be your story doesn't have to be born
the website doesn't have to be born your
product doesn't have to be boring it's
just what it is now and you can make it
that much better but a lot of people are
afraid right you're too afraid to take a
risk and do something that people might
not accept my lot like might not enjoy
so it's safer just to take the boring
path that everybody else is taking and I
would much rather risk doing something
that I'm passionate about and creative
and expressive in and it not working
then just stick to doing the same old
boring thing over and over and over and
over again and you box yourself in and
you stay in that box for the rest of
your life and you're too afraid to come
out of it because you afraid that what
will happen so tie this to the book
giving you guys an update we're in the
final stages of getting the book all
together all the kind of dotted i's and
cross the t's a my publisher asked me
for what I wanted to put in my
acknowledgement section and I looked at
most authors and what's in there
acknowledgement section and it's so
boring and like I do not want to have a
boring acknowledgement section if I'm
going to write it if I'm gonna have an
acknowledgement section at all it's
gotta be something that is not born
because I can't have this amazing book
and then lead with a really boring
ignoring suction it's got to be
different it's gonna be creative it's
gotta be unique and so I'm trying to
think I'm [ __ ] that cough which I
think what do I want to write like
what's different what's unique what's
what's an expression of myself how could
I inject insane emotion and believe into
something that most people wouldn't care
so much about it it's one page to the
annulment section right inside
deal but I don't want to have glory in
my book piri I don't have born in my
life and this is this is a microcosm
this is one example right if you set up
a boy once you'll keep settling settling
settling settling and so I can boast a
couple ideas I send it off to my
publisher I haven't heard back we'll see
what happens but regardless like even if
that doesn't work or even though I
decided to change my mind next week I'm
glad that I took that chance and I took
the risk and what I will end up with is
not just some boring and gone to suction
that everybody else has so take a good
look at everything that you're doing
look at your website and your marketing
and your product and how you talk to
customers and your email signature and
you know how you started YouTube for
everything look at everything and inject
a little bit of creativity there's a
lack of creativity in every field and
this is your chance to rise it up and do
something special and stop being boring
in your business I'm excited today I
don't know a lot of time but let's pump
into a couple of questions because you
guys took the time to ask them so I want
to at least answer a few of them for you
first up is new future builder love the
endless value here thanks bro appreciate
that after the book perhaps you do these
videos occasionally for your journey of
growing TDs I think as an entrepreneur
it's amazing to hear what challenges
other business owners face as they work
through them so he's referring to trauma
thanks also it's a business that I was a
an investor in and acquired at the
beginning of this year and became the
sole owner of it's interesting I see
that eventually becoming its own show
and having like a professional camera
crew come in and follow it along as a
reality show but as a positive reality
show the thing that's helped me back at
least for now is exposing and exposing a
team and giving them ready for I know
it's possible doing a way that is this
positive and uplifting I just need to
get people used to being on camera and
having it seen as a positive but i agree
i think there is a lot that we can tell
the story i try to incorporate some of
the things that are happening in my
espresso on some of the videos that I'm
doing but I could see it becoming its
own series i had high
Alex who helps me run the business on
the channel number of times but I'm glad
that that opportunity come I'm glad
you're thinking along those lines cuz i
am too it's probably coming it's mulling
it small and it's sitting in here
something's going to happen it's
probably coming but i'll keep you guys
posted and i appreciate the suggestion
next up is Alec evan is yellow
entrepreneur my friends and even people
i meet sometimes asking questions on how
to be successful or anything along the
lines of entrepreneurship currently I
don't think that I'm not far enough in
the process to answer each question how
do you feel the situation i'm sure you
have this problem as you evolved in
business as well so i don't think I have
the answer to every single question but
I believe that I can answer many
questions and it's just from my own
experience right if somebody asked me
about something that I don't know
anything about then i will say how i
would tackle it right if somebody asked
me how do i start a painting business
I've never seen a painting business I
don't have a lot of contacts around the
pinking industry but I can give advice
patient on how I went started painting
business and how I would try to model
success and who I would try to partner
up with and I believe that that's
valuable helpful interesting for that
entrepreneur if you're talking to me
about something that I have tangible
practical how-to knowledge on like how
do I start a YouTube channel or how do i
create videos or how do I build a
software company or how do I raise
capital things I've had experience with
that I can go a little bit deeper on
those topics if you don't know the
answer then say you don't know like I
try to answer the question that I feel
like I can provide some value and some
context around but if somebody asked me
you know a legal question or an
accounting question that I don't know
the answer to think I'm not a lawyer or
an accountant I think it's probably
better for you to go talk to the expert
that being said I think that if people
are asking you the questions then they
see you as being further ahead than they
are and there is probably more that you
can offer than you currently are so let
me break that down a little bit I think
a lot of people discount their value
they discount their story they feel like
I'm not far enough ahead they feel like
you know I'm here but I want to be up
here and so because there's that big gap
you feel like you're not successful but
remember even though there is this gap
you're here and there's people who are
here there's people who haven't quit
their job yet who haven't even thought
about their business idea yet who have a
lot of fear who you know they look up to
your story and they can learn something
from you and even though you're not way
up here you're still ahead of them and
this is a big gap that you can help fill
with the answers so i think it's if
you're getting questions one try to help
right you want to get back you want to
see people follow their journey if you
know the answer great offer it to them
if you don't then you can give them the
honest feedback that hey like don't
pertain to answer question you don't
have the knowledge on but I think that
you could probably add value to people's
lives and help them more than you think
you can don't discount your value don't
discount that the path that you've
already taken and how much I has helped
you and how that can be an inspiration
to other people as well I get this a lot
when people are telling your story and
they're trying to make their story
relevant and helpful in informational
for potential customers and if you like
I haven't done much and like my stories
on interesting and it's not about you
it's about the connection to you it's
about me feeling like you care about
this business it's about me feeling like
you've done a lot of research and you've
done your homework and you're super
passionate about it that's what I'm
going to go with you or some big company
that you know has the brand name and
reputation or i'm just going to beat you
down on price because i feel like you're
connected to the business I feel like
you really deeply meaningfully care
about what you're doing then i'ma go and
buy from you don't discount what you've
done so far and may not be where you
want to be but it's ahead of a lot of
other people and you can be an
inspiration to them next up is Jonathan
how do you make the videos pop into a
smaller video I'm trying to do the same
thing in my videos at the end for a call
to action for newsletter opting but I'm
having trouble figuring this out ever
you have suggestions or does anyone else
have an answer thanks so Jonathan I'm
not a video editor back to that last
question of answer the questions that
you know what I first started my channel
I did everything myself but the videos
were not
amazingly edited and I didn't know how
to put video inside another video now
I've hired a team people help me and at
the core of the editing side is
Christina and her husband Sam so
Christina I don't know if you have any
advice to give the jonathan i have an
added video inside another video you can
look it up hey Jonathan picture and
picture is pretty simple to do take a
look in every editing software you have
at least future ex for video so main
video or some graphic or picture you
should put on the bottom and then on the
top just add video you want to be
smaller after that just you skill to
you can drop shadow at s emotion to make
it look better next up a mere really
excited for the audiobook thank you
there seems to be a ton of momentum and
energy around the audio book which is
interesting and surprising at the start
I wasn't sure proof i'm going to get an
audio book and now obviously has been
confirmed i mentioned that in an old
episode of the book series i'm curious
how many of you guys are looking forward
to the audiobook version and not so much
the written one and why do you love
audio books so much I don't listen to
any audio books I don't listen to
podcast most of you does at all I feel
like it's because I don't have a commute
and when I I home or when I'm working I
would much rather have a youtube video
on where there's a visual then just
listen in the background so if I'm
listening to the school of greatness
which I love from Louis house I'll watch
the video won't listen to the podcast
but I'm curious how you consume
audiobooks and why there's so much
momentum of energy i'm just your own
personal experience leave that in the
comments and last question from paul
always in hustle mode december six is
fate of a publication thanks it seems
like it's so far away when i first
started this journey it's crazy how long
it takes to get a book not just written
but all the stuff that has to happen to
get it out and market it and publish and
as an entrepreneur that's tough because
you know we want things now right we
would I don't have patience man I want
something that happen immediately when i
get working on something i will will it
into existence and it will happen i
build up massive momentum and i think
that's what entrepreneurs do i'm sure
that's what do you guys do it's not like
yeah I want to update my whatever page
of my website I'll do it I'll do it next
month or something as soon as you have a
pain you want to go and solve it so it's
frustrating that it takes so long in the
book out but it's nice to have a final
date it's nice to have something that
we're working towards and so even though
we are in June now thinking December is
so far away but it's not compared to
where we started and so I'm really
excited and I thank you guys for the
support and follow me on this journey
and I'm looking forward to future
updates and keeping you posted it's been
a fun experience making this video
series 22
but kind of expose what goes in to
making a deal with a large publisher and
yeah I'll keep you posted and super
excited so thank you guys so much for
watching if you have a question for me
about not being boring which was the
topic of the day if you have a question
about my book or the book writing
process leave it in the comments below
and I will answer you in next week's
video thank you guys so much for
watching your support means a lot to me
i can't tell you how much continue to
believe and i'll see you soon